As we can see here, early on in the World Cup games,
the games involving the home team were actually very well attended.
But as time's gone on,
depending on the year, sometimes the home team's not even in the tournament.
Or there's other potentially more interesting games which have
a higher attendance rates than the ones involving the home team.
One hypothesis for why this might be happening very early on is that many of
the fans who show up to the games are from the home country,
due to the fact it might be hard to get to a given World Cup
with the current state of transportation and technologies.
As flying became more commonplace, as airlines have blown up, maybe over
the years it's just much easier for teams and fans to get around the world.